qui mesure l'oxygène et bien d'autres choses.
Nous commençons sur le fleuve Mississippi,
nous sillonnons le golfe du Mexique jusqu'au Texas,
je rentre même parfois discrètement dans les eaux du Texas pour les tester.
En mesurant l'oxygène au fond de l'eau,
on peut dresser une carte de toutes les zones en dessous de deux,
le taux minimum à partir duquel les poissons commencent à quitter la zone.
Je plonge aussi dans cette zone morte.
On a des oxymètres qui doivent être déployés en mer
pour nous donner des mesures en continu des teneurs en oxygène.
Quand vous plongez dans l'eau, il y a beaucoup de poissons.
Des tonnes de poissons, de toutes sortes,
comme mon ami en photo ici, le barracuda, que j'ai pu voir, un jour.
Tout le monde allaient dans une direction, moi de l'autre, avec mon appareil photo.
(Rires)
10 mètres plus bas, il y a de moins en moins de poissons.
Puis, vous arrivez au fond
et vous ne voyez plus aucun poisson.
Il n'y a pas de vie à cet endroit, aucune forme de vie n'évolue ici.
Vous savez que vous êtes dans la zone morte.
Quel lien y a-t-il entre la région centrale des États-Unis
et le golfe du Mexique ?
La plupart des bassins versants sont des terres agricoles.
Et notamment, une rotation des cultures de maïs et de soja.
L'azote des engrais et le phosphore se répandent sur les terres
et s'écoulent dans le fleuve Mississippi,
avant de finir dans le golfe du Mexique.
Il y a trois fois plus d'azote dans l'eau
du Mississippi aujourd'hui,
qu'en 1950.
Trois fois plus.
Et la quantité de phosphore a doublé.
Il y a donc plus de phytoplancton et moins d'oxygène.
Ce n'est pas une caractéristique du golfe, c'est une cause de l'activité humaine.
Le paysage n'est plus ce qu'il était.
Autrefois, il y avait des prairies, des forêts, des fondrières,
des habitats pour les canards et pour tous les êtres vivants.
C'est fini maintenant, les champs cultivés les ont remplacés.
Il y a plusieurs façons de traiter ce genre d'agriculture,
en utilisant moins d'engrais chimiques, en fertilisant de façon ciblée
et en donnant sa chance à l'agriculture durable.
Par exemple, l'agropyre intermédiaire a des racines plus longues
de 15 centimètres que celles du maïs :
elles aident à garder l'azote dans le sol, ce qui prévient l'érosion des sols.
Comment convaincre nos voisins du nord,
habitant peut-être à 1 500 km, voire plus,
que leurs activités altèrent la qualité des eaux du golfe du Mexique ?
Tout d'abord, on peut leur montrer ce qui se passe chez eux.
L'été, dans le Wisconsin, en allant se baigner
dans votre point d'eau préféré,
vous pourriez trouver quelque chose comme ça.
C'est la même apparence et la même odeur que de la peinture verte étalée
à la surface de l'eau.
C'est une prolifération d'algues vertes toxiques,
nocives pour l'homme.
De même, sur le Lac Érié, il y a quelques étés,
il y avait des centaines de kilomètres de ces algues vertes :
la ville de Toledo dans l'Ohio n'a pas pu l'utiliser pour son réseau d'eau potable
pendant plusieurs jours à la suite.
Si vous regardez les informations,
vous savez que beaucoup de communautés ont des problèmes d'eau potable.
Je suis une scientifique.
Je ne sais pas si ça se remarque.
(Rires)
Je cherche des faits scientifiques solides, puis je publie mes résultats.
Mes collègues les lisent et citent mon travail.
Je crois vraiment qu'en tant que scientifique,
utilisant surtout des fonds fédéraux pour financer mes recherches,
c'est mon devoir envers le grand public,
les directeurs d'agences et les représentants au Congrès,
de partager mes connaissances avec eux
afin qu'ils puissent les utiliser et prendre de meilleures décisions
pour notre politique environnementale.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Une des façons d'y arriver, c'est d'en parler dans les médias.
Joby Warrick, du Washington Post,
a placé cette photo dans un article
en une de l'édition du dimanche, bien visible.
C'était un gros coup.
Le sénateur de la Louisiane, John Breaux,
a réagi : « Mon Dieu, c'est comme ça qu'ils voient le golfe du Mexique ? »
J'ai répondu : « Eh bien, en voici la preuve
et on doit réagir à ça. »
Au même moment, Olympia Snowe, la sénatrice du Maine,
luttait contre l'arrivée d'algues nocives dans le golfe du Maine.
Ils ont joint leurs forces – c'était une action bipartite –
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Ils m'ont invitée à venir témoigner au Congrès.
J'ai dit : « J'ai seulement suivi les crabes jusqu'au sud du Texas,
je ne sais que dire de plus. »
(Rires)
Mais je l'ai fait.
(Acclamations)
Finalement, la loi a été votée.
Elle a été intitulée – eh oui –
Loi de 1998 sur la Recherche et le Contrôle de la Prolifération
des Algues Nocives et de l'Hypoxie.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
C'est pourquoi on l'appelle la Loi Snowe-Breaux.
(Rires)
Par ailleurs, en 2001, on a donné une conférence,
organisée par l'Académie nationale des sciences,
sur les engrais, l'azote et la faible qualité de l'eau.
L'oratrice de la plénière était l'ancienne gouverneure
de l’État du New Jersey.
Et elle...
C'était évident qu'elle était très sérieuse quand elle a fixé le public
et j'ai pensé : « Elle me regarde sûrement.
- Vous savez, j'en ai vraiment assez qu'on compare cette chose au New Jersey.
Prenez n'importe quel autre État, je ne veux juste plus entendre ça. »
Mais elle a pu faire avancer le plan d'action
jusqu'au bureau du président George W. Bush,
afin d'avoir des objectifs environnementaux
que nous nous efforçons d'atteindre.
Le Midwest ne nourrit pas le monde entier,
mais il alimente beaucoup de poulets, de porcs, de bétail
et il produit beaucoup d'éthanol,
utilisé comme carburant
et régulé par la politique fédérale.
Nous pouvons faire mieux que cela.
Nous devons prendre des décisions
pour consommer moins
et diminuer notre dépendance à l'azote.
C'est comme l'empreinte carbone.
Chacun peut réduire son empreinte azote.
Pour y arriver, je ne mange pas trop de viande –
même si j'aime parfois en manger un peu –
en n'utilisant pas d'huile de maïs,
et en conduisant une voiture qui roule à l'essence sans éthanol,
avec une meilleure consommation au kilomètre.
Ces petites choses peuvent faire la différence.
Alors, je vous mets au défi, pas seulement vous,
mais aussi beaucoup de gens, en particulier dans le Midwest –
pensez à votre façon de traiter la terre et à comment changer les choses.
J'avance à petits pas.
Modifier le modèle agricole des États-Unis
sera un pas de géant.
Et pour y arriver, il faudra beaucoup de volonté politique et sociale.
Mais on peut le faire.
Je suis convaincue que nous pouvons expliquer la science,
la relier à la politique et changer les choses pour notre environnement.
Nous voulons tous un environnement sain.
Nous pouvons travailler ensemble en ce sens
pour éliminer ces zones mortes dans le golfe du Mexique.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)